hey 42 here more people in the world
currently suffer from obesity than from
hunger welcome to RIF the world's
longest piece of music lasts an
astonishing 639 years it is called as
slow as possible there are currently
more vacant houses than homeless people
in the United States when adjusted to
account for inflation john d rockefeller
was the richest man to have ever lived
with a net worth 10 times greater than
Bill Gates in Los Angeles there are more
cars than people the average 4 year old
asks over 400 questions a day the
population of Ireland today is still 2
million less than it was before the
potato famine over a hundred and sixty
years ago just as some people talk in
their sleep sign language speakers have
been known to sign in their sleep whilst
Pixar was making Toy Story 2 someone
accidentally ran a UNIX command which
deleted the entire films data off of
their service it was restored thanks to
an animator who kept a copy of it at
home so she could work on it whilst at
home starfish can regrow their arms if
cut off in fact a single arm can
regenerate a whole body
lots of raptors were actually only about
as big as a modern-day Turkey
statistically going to work is three
times more dangerous than war
Shakespeare told the first-ever
yo mama joke if you ever run out of
candles a single crayon will burn for 30
minutes in 2008 pet hamsters were banned
in Vietnam thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2